em 1995 foi aprovada no vestibular de
medicina
finalmente eu ia salvar vidas e saber
como as pessoas que salvam vidas se
sentem primeiro segundo ela nada de
salvar vidas
tínhamos muitas matérias é que até hoje
não em compreender tudo o que elas estão
fazendo lá por exemplo em informática
médica gente em 1995 o que se imagina
gravação de disquete é recordo de um dia
ele já casa de um colega que tinha a pau
internet na casa dele e nós 5 ao redor
dele ficamos olhando o que ele escreveu
a palavra que nunca saiu da minha cabeça
google e ali ele colocou o nome de uma
doença e apareceram várias linhas em
azul e fiquei pensando será que algum
dia eu vou aprender a mexer nesse tal de
google
vamos para o terceiro ano
nesse momento eu ia aprender é salvar
vidas
não ainda não mas a gente começou a ver
paciente
eu me recordo de irmos aos quartos aos
leitos os pacientes acompanhados do
professor e nós
um grupo de cinco pessoas nós entrávamos
no quarto e muitas vezes não estávamos
em um bom dia e não perguntávamos o nome
daquela pessoa
essa realidade foi acontecendo todos os
dias e eu fui me acostumando
horrorosamente
vieram os 4º e 5º ano de medicina
quando nós examinavam os pacientes nas
enfermarias de obstetrícia
éramos dois ou três alunos a fazer o
toque vaginal naquela paciente grávida
neurologia acontecer a mesma coisa com
os pacientes prostáticos ou com algum
problema de próstata
nós tocávamos geralmente duas pessoas
aquele mesmo paciente eu fazia uma forma
mais profissional que eu sabia mas não
era profissional era estudante
uma estudante completamente envergonhada
eu não sabia como agir
bom o tempo passou e me formei
fisiologia pediátrica e atende muitas
pessoas é é achando que eu estava dando
o melhor de mim
uma parte teórica
eu tentei de todas as formas querer
salvar aquelas crianças mas muitas vezes
a parte humana não esteve tão perfeita
quanto eu gostaria
naquela época é só conhecia a simpatia a
compaixão a pena
eu nunca tinha ouvido falar uma palavra
empatia nunca
então hoje em dia eu sinto dor porque
naquela época não conhecer o recorde de
uma paciente que houve formei a mãe da
criança que ela iria pro transplante de
medula
essa mãe entrou em desespero e xororó e
eu não sabia muito bem como agir
ela era de fora ela é passar algumas
horas em porto alegre
ele disse que de quem sabe tu vai
descansar um pouco é uma volta no
shopping
essa paciente nunca mais voltou
tempos depois eu agradeço porque ela me
escreveu dizendo porque ela achou que eu
tinha analisado a doença da filha dela
que o mandela é passear no shopping
realmente não foi uma abordagem eu não
fui nem um pouco empática passado isso a
palavra empatia ou melhor dizendo a
palavra empatia ea medicina mudaram
completamente meu jeito de de 2015
tudo mudou através da história de uma
colega que eu queria dividir com vocês
o do homem no vídeo 2015 novembro de
é o mundo todo estava assustado com os
ataques em pareci e essa minha colega
grávida de 26 semanas acariciar a
barriga enquanto fazia mala vai para o
congresso no dia seguinte
só que desde depois ela anunciou que seu
consciente e foi levada principal
chegando lá ela fez um raio-x e olhou e
ela mesmo viu que tinha um tumor no
pulmão
a partir dali tudo se modificou
nunca nada foi o mesmo
foi pedido para ela decidir se a filha
não seria o faria cni ainda qual é o
nome do homem
a mãe decidiu por fazer a criança nascer
não queria uma carga de quimioterapia no
bebê
helena nasceu helena assim como veio se
foi um ou dois dias mas ela é ainda mãe
de um outro uma pazinha de sete anos ela
tinha que viver então ela foi procurar
os melhores é os melhores profissionais
do brasil é tentar ajudar a procurar por
que ela foi diagnosticada com uma bela o
carcinoma estádio quatro que significa
avançado improvável
ela foi consultar os profissionais é
extremamente técnicos e ela disse pra um
deles mas tutor eu li que 1% dos
pacientes sobrevivem em um ano
é verdade não é né
e ele levantou a cabeça em dois segundos
e disse sim no melhor das hipóteses
no mesmo dia ela foi em outra consulta
onde médico disse pra ela viaje reagir
muito volte a necessidade de viagem
eu não sei vocês mas tirando os filmes
de hollywood
a gente não tem vontade de viajar e
deixar nossa família quando não estão um
diagnóstico tão grave
uma mulher de 38 anos ela voltou voltou
e lala começou o tratamento com o médico
dela que não tem toda a tecnologia e os
outros hospitais mas tinha uma coisa
muito diferente
a empatia
e assim seguiu o tratamento 2016 2017
nos 29 sendo que logo em 2016 já tinha
se despedido de muita gente
até que chegou um momento que não tinha
mais gente vai se despedindo e aí ela
pensou será que eu repito que hoje a
dent alma da shell de novo mas não ela
decidiu a de viver
o renda melhor viver vivendo e nesse
período
houveram muitas e muitas palavras é não
agradáveis e dados de uma forma notícias
dadas de maneiras incorretas
em 2009 ela foi diagnosticada com e
tasci cerebrais gigantescas e ela
escolheu operado ainda na uti ela
conversou com a médica que não queria
dar alta para a paciente é o paciente
saiu de casa
raspou o cabelo pela primeira vez na
vida e foi pro hospital é crente de que
aquela cirurgia e daria mais vida ea
médica não quis da alta porque a
paciente chorava demais
chorava muito chorar a gente não é não
significa suicídio é ela ficou
extremamente ofendida com aquilo porque
ela queria ver o médico intensivista
falou que tinha suspeita de suicídio pro
colega dela e quando entrou no quarto
essa minha amiga só disse olha a doutora
esse espírito espírita se matou
elas disseram então que a então vou te
dar ok
e assim foi a avaliação psicológica
assim a vaga olímpica
seria enfim espírito não se matam foi
que ela a justificativa dela e nesse
período
então em que tudo mudou eu com a minha
amiga eu comecei a entender o que era
empatia e fui estudar uma empatia eu vi
que existe dentro de nós
a fábrica da empatia a gente já nasce
com ela é remoto não é algo é
psicológico não é a empatia ela pode ser
treinada é a capacidade de se colocar no
lugar do outro sendo que aquela aquela
máxima que existe de caça para o outro o
que você gostaria que fizesse para você
não é válido
faça para o outro o que você não
gostaria que fizesse pra você porque o
outro pode ter os gostos e as opiniões
diferentes de você
após verificar que como funcionava a
empatia eu comecei a entender e não
entender o porquê que não acontecia esse
ensinamento nas faculdades porque não
tinha tido aula de empatia porque o que
aconteceu
a empatia é feita através dos nossos
neurônios espelho e me espelho no olho
em mim o que eu vejo no outro a nossa
capacidade de audição
nós temos a capacidade de ouvir mas a
audição tem que ser uma audição completa
você tem que ouvir a pessoa o que ela
está falando
chegando à conclusão de que a empatia
pode ser treinada e que existem
protocolos para isso pra treinamento de
alunos e treinamento de profissionais
eu pensei por que não aprende o que
aconteceu
bom gente é
eu não consigo citam empática vamos
colocar no lugar de ninguém
é essa minha amiga sou eu e eu operei o
crânio
há mais ou menos três meses que tem nem
radioterapia há dois meses que estou
aqui e hoje em dia é me dói mais saber a
falta de empatia que eu tive com os
outros do que a falta de empatia que
tiveram comigo porque toda vez que
acontecia algo que eu pensava nos será
que eu fui assim
será que eu fiz dessa maneira e eu fui
me utilizando como um estudo uma pós
graduação já que era médica e
oncologista
por que não usar isso como uma pós
graduação
então hoje eu estudo empatia e tenta
ensinar a empatia uma maioria e os
estudantes que eu conheço é porque não
existe dor pior do que você entrar numa
faculdade querendo salvar vidas e você
prejudica essas vidas por falta desse
detalhe
a empatia eu não quero que ninguém passe
por essa dor enquanto eu sentia adora eu
sentia muito remorso por não ter sido
também do empate com aquelas crianças e
com aquelas mais
então a minha função neste momento é da
vida ela acredita que eu cheguei até
aqui pra poder compreender tudo isso é
repassá-lo para o mundo que nós
precisamos de empatia na medicina em
qualquer outra área mas a medicina
ela é primordial
muito obrigada